there is nothing like a hot cup of tea
in the morning that is until I'm done
and I have to decide what to do with my
cup can I recycle it is it a trick
question
yeah this is a great question and I just
figure you can recycle anything that's
hardboard ask i can't recycle this
[Music]
knowing what you can and can't recycle
isn't easy the rules depend on where you
live and there are hundreds of products
and materials where the rules aren't
always clear
I hear that that's not recyclable I
don't know if that's like a legend an
urban legend or something hate fruit
towels my roommate and I actually have
this discussion where I'm like I'll
throw paper towels in there and she's
like I don't think you can recycle then
she'll pick them out like I don't know
it's paper
the confusion means that things that are
actually garbage still end up in the
recycling stream about 25% of what
Americans try to recycle can't actually
be recycled waste management experts say
what's going on here is something called
aspirational recycling when people are
unsure if an item can be recycled they
recycle it because it feels like the
right thing to do
and while our intentions are good this
behavior isn't harmless even small
amounts of contamination can turn entire
halls of otherwise recyclable materials
into trash and the problem has been
growing the rate of recycling
contamination more than doubled in the
last decade so why is this happening
well it's at least in part due to a
major shift in how Americans recycled
beginning in the 1990s and 2000's
municipalities implemented single stream
recycling programs
paper metal plastic and glass no longer
needed to be sorted they could all live
in one bin communities quickly adopted
the practice and by 2014
80% of all curbside recycling programs
in the US were single-stream the problem
is there's evidence that when we put all
our recycling into one bin or more
likely to throw trash in there along
with it take to neighboring counties in
Florida for example Palm Beach County
where residents must priests or their
recyclables had a contamination rate of
only nine percent while Broward County's
single stream program had a
contamination rate of thirty percent
single stream recycling takes the
responsibility to sort off of the
individual and shifts it to materials
recovery facilities or Murph's where
trash gets sorted from recycling by
machines but also by workers who often
have to remove waste by hand pizza boxes
contaminated with grease electronics
that aren't processed at standard
recycling facilities even the likes of
Christmas lights animal carcasses and
bowling balls in Portland workers remove
thousands of dirty diapers every month
in a perfect world everyone would just
know how to recycle correctly but short
of that there's something we can all
start doing differently right now unless
you are absolutely sure don't recycle it
in fact recycling education campaigns
encourage the opposite when in doubt the
best option may be to throw it out most
people want to do the right thing and
sometimes the way to be a good recycler
is to throw stuff in the trash if you
liked this video and want more like it
we've launched a paid membership program
on YouTube called the Fox video lab for
monthly fees subscribers get access to
DVD extras live cue days with creators
and video recommendations you can go to
box com slash join and be part of the
video lab community see you there